My white blood cell count is very low.
I have leukemia.
How can I increase my white blood cell count?
Help.
Again, what if I know why?
So why does a person have low white blood cell count?
So if the person has low white blood cell count
because they have cancer, they have a diagnosis of cancer,
they've been dealing with cancer.
Maybe they went through chemotherapy
and then they have chronic low white blood cell count
because of that.
That is a common thing that we do with here.
You can also have low white blood cell count
because of chronic infection.
So somebody has like a chronic Epstein bar,
especially a chronic viral infection,
can just drain their white blood cell count.
So that can be a cause of white blood cell count.
But you do want to find out why.
So, and then boosting your white blood cell count
is not very easy.
So you could do things to help support white blood cell production.
Medicinal mushrooms can be beneficial.
There's, again, it's so, I hate to get too technical here
because it depends on what you got going on.
If you have an autoimmune disease,
then you have to be careful of taking a bunch of immune stimulants.
So a person with a chronic autoimmune disease
could also have suppressed white blood cell count.
And then if you're going to take immune stimulators
like vitamin C and things like that
that are going to be natural stimulators,
like herbal, echinacea, a straggleness,
and things like that that you think of
if you take, if you had a infection
or a viral infection or a bacterial infection,
it can make you worse.
So you do want to discern and get a differential diagnosis
whether you have an autoimmune disease as well.
If you know that you have an autoimmune disease
then I would stay with the medicinal mushrooms
and invite them in D.
I would get your vitamin D level checked as well.
Many times the low white blood cell count
a person can have a vitamin D level of about 30.
That's very low in my book.
You want to get it, you know, at least twice that much.
Getting your vitamin D elevated can be helpful
using medicinal mushrooms can be helpful.
And the reason why I say sticky to those two
if you have an autoimmune disease
because those are immune regulators.
They're not immune stimulators.
So they will help bring up your white blood cell count
if it's low, but they won't bring it up excessively
if it's already high.
Versus immune stimulators like different herbals,
like a mentioned straggalists and anacidacea
and you have a bite of it C and even SIG.
Taking something that you would take
thinking that you have a bad cold
or you're coming down with something
that is an immune stimulator is not a good thing to take
if you have an autoimmune disease
because you're going to increase the attack on salt tissue.
So really sometimes it's hard to answer any questions
because I don't know the background.
So everybody's a little bit different
and it's not a simple answer.